سنكون معكم في تصور اقرب لعمليه الطائرات
المسيره قربه لكريم لان عمليه ارست هذه
معك محمود الزيبق سنتابعها في هذا التطور
اللافت بالتاكيد ازدهار نتابع اذا هي خطوه
قالت موسكو انها محاوله الاغتيال الرئيس
فلاديمير بوتين وصفتها بالارهابيه واحتفظت
لنفسها بحق الرد في الزمان والمكان
المناسبين عليها الان لاحظوا هذه الصوره
هنا نتجه الان الى الخريطه هذه هي المنطقه
منطقه الكريملان هذه هي المنطقه القبه
التي شاهدناها هي هذه القبه هنا قبه
الكريم وطبعا زميرنا زاور شاوج كان يقف
هنا على حافه نهر موسكووفا الذي شاهدناه
في الفيديو هو اتجاه طائره مسيره من هذه
الجهه داخل سماء موسكو باتجاه قبه
الكرملين حيث تم اسقاطها هنا او ظهرت بقعه
نار في الطائره المسيره في هذه المنطقه
فيما يشير الى اسقاط الطائره المسيره في
هذا المكان هذا الذي شاهدناه في الفيديو
لكن ما نعرفه حتى الان من المعلومات
المتوفره ان القوات ان موسكو منعت طيران
اي طائرات مسيره داخل العاصمه موسكو ليس
معلوما بالضبط حتى الان نوع الطائرات التي
تم اسقاطها وفقا لما توفر المعلومات
الاوليه ليس معلوما اذا كانت بعيده المدى
او قصيره المدى ايضا هل اطلقت من موسكو
لكن لدينا اكثر من تصور اذا كانت اطلقت من
داخل العاصمه موسكو فنحن نتحدث عن مدى
تحدث عنه زميلنا زاور قبل قليل في مداخلته
قال ان القطر تقريبا سيكون حوالي 70 كيلو
متر اذا كانت الطائرات قد اطلقت من داخل
روسيا لكن اذا اتجهنا الى سيناريو اخر
محتمل وقلنا ان الطائرات ربما اطلقت من
هنا لتصل الى موسكو اذا بحثنا عن اقرب
نقطه في شمال الاوكراني سواء في شمال سومي
او خارجيف باتجاه هذا الاتجاه باتجاه
موسكو نحن نتحدث هنا عن مسافه تقدر ب 470
الى 500 كيلومتر على الاقل هذه المسافه
المفترض ان الطائره المسيره قطعتها داخل
الاجواء الروسيه الى ان وصلت الى مبنى
الكريمينا لكن طبعا هذا سيناريو نحن كما
ذكرنا سابقا ليس هناك معلومات حتى عن نوع
المسيرات عن المدى التي تبلغه المعلومات
الاوليه التي توفرت لدينا كانت حتى الان
هي ان الطائره شوهدت فوق قبه الكريملين
هنا تماما وتم تفجيرها او ربما تم نسفها
في هذه المنطقه مره اخرى هنا قرب قبه
الكريم لان هذه التي تشاهدونها وسالون قبه
الكريم مره اخرى باللون الاخضر التي
شاهدناها في الصوره كانت هنا الطائره حيث
تم اسقاطها وحيث راينا النيران تشتعل فيها
في اشاره الى اسقاط هذه
الطائره طبعا هذا المشهد هو يشابه هذا
المشهد الذي رايناه هناك كما تشاهدون
القبه مره اخرى حيث تم اسقاط الطائره